why did you have self-hatred if people
are looking out you have this big family
and big life so everything should be
great right right but it isn't yeah I
think that started from my childhood you
know and really being the child of two
addicts which is no you know it's no
fault of my parents because they had
their own challenges to deal with and
they had their own illness right in fact
there's a conversation you have with
your father which I had with mine as
well which is I can't be a father your
father said the same thing to you yes
wow and I fully understood that from him
I gave him that Grace I just said you
can't put on shoes and you don't have a
phone or a home or you know you're
transient you look like you are homeless
right and I think I was just so happy
that he gave me life yeah and I it took
me a while to get to that point with my
father because when he told me I was
seven which even at that I was seven too
that's what I had the conversation no
there's so much I whether it's the
nightclubs and the hanging out and the
music and everything you are so not who
I thought you were and I didn't know who
to think you were okay we're going
backwards okay you grew up in Baltimore
you have these two sets of grandparents
first of all your your grandmother Maran
yes got pregnant at 13 yes she did she
got pregnant at 13 and had to give up
her child for adoption and then she went
into the fost care system yeah and then
my mother when she got pregnant at a
young age 17 17 my grandmother was like
you have to get married and if your
father hadn't said yes to getting
married which he ultimately knew he
wasn't probably capable of but they went
forward and you have your life yeah yeah
because she said you either get married
to my daughter or we're going to give
the child up for adoption or we're she's
going to have an abortion yeah yeah so I
realized at a later age I was like you
know what thank you for that yes even
though you knew you weren't going to be
a capable father but it gave it put my
life on the trajectory that it needed to
be and I became the the apple of my
grandmother's eye I mean I became the
love of her life Mar who was such a big
Force but when I'm reading the book and
I'm picturing you at 13 walking to
7-Eleven to meet the boy that kid who
grows up in Baltimore that staying up
all night the sort of double life with
par they're off doing Stu that's good
and also Shady you're off doing stuff
that's good and shady I can't tell you
how much I relate to that like I was I
got emancipated and lived on my own at
14 and by then I was ready like I had
been in an institution for years I had
been you know even kids today if they're
making my kids are making crank calls
and you know texting with friends and
wanting to wear crop tops what I was
doing at their age okay and the thing
with the will thing and the slap you
said in the book there's no blood
there's no guns and I had the moment
where I was like do you and I have such
a skewed sense of reality that's been
put on such a fast track due to our
upbringing that unless it's really crazy
we don't consider it that crazy or at
least it didn't get that
[Music]
crazy